so i'd like to share with you the best
protocol
for not only bipolar disorder but ocd
obsessive compulsive disorder and i
first just want to mention this is not
to replace your medical care check with
your doctor before implementing this i
just want to give you another viewpoint
i want to give you another option
because it's very difficult to find
a protocol
that would really
potentially work for you and
unfortunately the current treatment for
these two conditions
have a lot of side effects first of all
there's mega ssris and those are
medications that
inhibit the reuptake of serotonin so you
increase the serotonin in the body and
then they potentially might give you
intravenous chlomepramine or deep brain
stimulation where they're putting wires
into your brain or even functional
neurosurgery
so some people might even consider
you're getting a chemical lobotomy but
when you look up alternatives for these
conditions you'll see that yeah
alternative treatments are dangerous and
they might have side effects but for
example fish oils was given to someone
like 10 times the normal value and and
they had some side effects but what
about all the drug side effects and
really what is the potential reason why
you might have these conditions in the
first place that's what i want to know
about but one thing to know is the
mechanism of of how some of these
medications work is through
manipulating neurotransmitters and
the missing information that a lot of
people need to know
related to that is that your gut your
friendly microbes
make a tremendous amount of
neurotransmitters so
if you have gut problems okay that you
better work on that because the
microbiome the friendly bacteria
are probably not making enough
neurotransmitters and i'm talking about
serotonin i'm talking about
norepinephrine
dopamine and so people who have bipolar
disorder have a much higher incidence of
inflammation in their gut than people
that don't have that condition so
there's definitely a connection so
here's the simple protocol
if you have gut issues okay fix that
first how do you do that i'll put some
videos down below but basically you need
to start consuming foods that give you
the pre pre-biotic
and the
probiotic so i'm talking about fermented
foods sauerkraut kimchi maybe a high
quality kefir
definitely a probiotic that alone can
create a huge stabilizing influence over
your mood and of course i'm going to
jump right down to six
one thing that will create inflammation
in your gut
is grains so you must
get rid of all grains in your diet as
well as sugar both of these things will
severely destroy your gut and i know
quite a few people who just get rid of
the gluten out of the diet and they also
cut down the sugar and
magically these symptoms go away so with
the gut you need to put in the good
bacteria and the good friendly microbes
and take away the things that are
causing the inflammation and i'm also
talking about the grain oils like soy
oil corn oil canola cottonseed oil those
oils are highly inflammatory number two
your brain works much better on a low
carb ketogenic diet than on a high carb
sugar diet so any time we're dealing
with mental
mood disorders or cognitive problems
your brain is going to be much happier
on ketones okay so you go low carb and
if you have gut problems
like ibs or
inflammation your gut
you may even want to do the carnivore
version of the ketogenic diet
where you're not introducing any plants
for some people that is very very
beneficial so we're going to run the
brain on ketones okay and support the
gut the two most important things
third most important thing is fish oils
okay now i recommend cod liver oil just
because it has some additional things
like vitamin d and vitamin a not to
mention the omega-3 fatty acids but
omega-3 fatty acids greatly reduces
inflammation in the brain and it's been
studied to produce a significant effect
for these disorders and by the way i'm
going to put those links down below but
a very good high quality fish oil is
essential and realize it does take
probably about a month to work so just
start taking it consistently and it's
going to help reduce inflammation in the
brain and it's going to support the
brain directly now the next thing that's
very very important is number four that
b vitamins your brain
needs b vitamins desperately
neurotransmitters work with the b
vitamins now if you have ocd
vitamin b1 is essential because it can
really help
control your focus
dramatically and get rid of nervous
tension as well so b1 is important and
folate okay folate not folic acid get
the folate version which is the natural
version very important and make sure
that you get natural b vitamins
nutritional yeast is a really good
source versus a lot of the synthetic
versions that they have now these are
mandatory but these are optional okay so
we have lithium orotate very effective
for bipolar disorder then you have
another one called n-acetyl cysteine
nac if you're going to get a product and
it's just as nac make sure it's the
n-acetyl cysteine which is very
effective for the
mania part of bipolar because it helps
to regulate glutamate which is an amino
acid in the brain now many times when
people have bipolar or ocd they may have
depression and if you have depression
hyperforin which is an extract of st
john's wort is a very effective antidote
for depression not to mention vitamin d
and then if you also have schizophrenia
i would recommend adding glycine but you
need to take a lot of it you want to
take 28 grams three times a day so
that's a total of 60 grams now you can
tell or make it by your weight you would
want to take 0.8 grams per kilogram of
weight if you want to get the exact
amount but this can also help greatly to
minimize
this condition right here and then you
might want to add the niacin which is
vitamin b3 to put the icing in the cake
because niacin has been known to
greatly improve schizophrenia
so anyway i just wanted to give you this
protocol so you have some alternative
plan
that you can use to help yourself
now at this point i think it's very very
important to get the basic eating plan
that you would need to get and for that
information i put that up right here
you